Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet
un peu spécial, d'un sujet qui est très populaire
en France, notamment chez les jeunes.
Ce n'est peut-être pas un sujet qui va vous intéresser ou qui vous intéresse,
mais regardez bien la vidéo parce que je pense que
je vais parler de sujet assez large
et que ce ne sera pas vraiment 100
% spécifique sur ce dont je vais parler.
Je suis très mystérieux et maintenant, je vais vous révéler
On va parler des mangas et notamment de Naruto, donc...
Pourquoi est-ce que j'ai envie de parler des mangas?
Bon, vous savez que j'adore le Japon,
j'apprend le Japonais, j'aime les mangas,
les animés, etc.
Mais la raison pour laquelle je pense que c'est intéressant pour vous,
C'est que les mangas c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement populaire en France,
c'est vraiment très populaire.
J'ai commencé à lire des mangas vers l'âge de 10-11 ans et à cette époque,
c'était pas très cool de lire des mangas, c'était même un peu nul.
mais depuis quelques années
Depuis, peut-être, 2018, 2019,
et d'autant plus avec le Covid après,
le Japon est devenu extrêmement populaire et les Mangas, c'est vraiment devenu
quelque chose de cool.
C'est tellement cool que, par exemple, dans beaucoup de...
de musique dans beaucoup même de morceaux de rap, il y a beaucoup
de références au manga.
Et du coup aujourd'hui j'avais envie de
parler de ça pour essayer de comprendre.
Pourquoi le manga, alors que c'est quelque chose d'assez spécifique,
est aussi populaire en France?
Il faut savoir que la France, c'est le deuxième marché mondial
pour le manga.
Après, Le Japon, bien évidemment.
C'est-à-dire que les Français, c'est la
deuxième consommation en manga après le Japon.
Donc, c'est vraiment hyper populaire.
Et c'est le marché numéro 1, on va dire, en dehors du Japon.
Et aujourd'hui, du coup, j'avais envie de me poser la question, d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi c'est aussi populaire.
Et pour ça, on va parler de scénarios, de
personnages, on va parler un peu de cinéma aussi,
donc je pense que ça va vous intéresser.
J'ai pris un exemple, enfin un livre, un manga de Naruto.
C'est l'exemple que je vais utiliser principalement tout au long de cette vidéo
parce que c'est le manga que je connais le mieux, je pense.
Mais ça s'applique à plusieurs, à d'autres mangas, bien évidemment.
Pour commencer, l'histoire culturelle, comment les mangas sont arrivés
en France et comment ils ont conquis la France.
Dans les années 90, il y avait une émission
de télé qui s'appelait le Club Dorothée.
Donc la présentatrice s'appelait Dorothée, je crois,
et c'était une émission en fait où il passait beaucoup de dessins animés
à la télé.
Bon moi, à cette époque, j'étais encore trop jeune, voire je n'étais pas né,
donc ce n'est pas une émission que j'ai beaucoup regardée, mais c'est vraiment via cette
émission que les animés ont commencé à passer à la télé française.
Et ça, je crois qu'à l'époque, il y avait...
Des animés comme les Chevaliers du Ciel, ce genre de choses, mais très rapidement,
en fait, il y a eu une certaine défiance.
Notamment une certaine défiance politique, une défiance c'est à dire...
C'est un peu s'opposer à quelque chose.
Je suis défiant envers les mangas, je suis un peu opposé aux mangas.
Et très rapidement, en fait, dans les médias et dans la politique,
il y a très rapidement eu des commentaires comme quoi les mangas,
les animés, c'était violent et débile, que ça ne servait à rien.
Et voilà, il y avait des exemples comme
avec Ken, le survivant, ou bon,
il me semble que c'est un mec très musclé
qui tue des gens avec une épée,
c'est un peu violent, mais du coup,
il y a vraiment eu très rapidement cette image comme quoi c'était
mauvais pour les jeunes de consommer des mangas, de regarder des animés
ou de lire des mangas.
Mais ensuite,
il y a eu un tournant générationnel et il y a eu des oeuvres
majeures qui ont marqué l'évolution du manga en France et dans le monde
d'ailleurs.
En premier il y a eu par exemple Dragon Ball, bien sûr,
et après je pense qu'en France il y a vraiment eu Naruto
et One Piece qui sont les deux œuvres
qui se sont imposées comme des classiques
et qui encore aujourd'hui sont considérées comme des classiques.
Quand j'avais 10 ans, je lisais Naruto, je lisais aussi One Piece,
il faut savoir que
c'est des séries qui sont très longues, c'est-à-dire que Naruto, ça s'est fini peut-être en...
2016/2018 je pense, et One Piece qui est
l'œuvre la plus longue, le manga le plus long,
c'est encore en train d'être publié.
Donc ça, ça a vraiment été les
tournants pour l'évolution du manga en France
avec ces trois œuvres qui ont vraiment marqué la jeunesse.
Je ne sais pas à quel point ça a joué dans l'évolution du manga en France,
mais en France on a quand même une culture
forte des bandes dessinées, donc les bandes dessinées, c'est l'équivalent du manga en France
ou l'équivalent du comic aux États-Unis, du manga au Japon, pardon,
et des comics aux États-Unis.
Donc la BD, on appelle ça la BD, on a une tradition BD franco-belge notamment,
les belges sont très forts en BD aussi et donc c'est quelque chose,
on a l'habitude de lire quand on est jeune.
Quand j'étais jeune, par exemple, je lisais beaucoup Lucky Luke,
qui est un peu plus vieux, mais qui continue de sortir, il y a aussi bien sûr
Astérix et Obelix, qui est un classique.
Et après, pour les plus jeunes, il y avait des choses comme Titeuf,
qui était hyper populaire, ou encore
par exemple Kid Paddle, Kid Paddle.
Et ça, c'est bon, là j'en ai cité quelques-uns, mais c'est vraiment des classiques
de classique.
Et énormément de Français lisent ce genre de...
De BD.
Titeuf, c'était vraiment générationnel
et tout le monde lisait les Titeufs.
Pareil, Lucky Luke, c'est plus vieux, mais voilà.
Vous avez plein d'œuvres comme ça, qui sont vraiment des classiques
pour des générations.
Et donc ça, d'un côté, c'est un peu l'équivalent japonais qui est arrivé
en France.
Alors,
À quel point ça a permis l'évolution du manga en France?
Je ne sais pas, mais en tout cas, on va dire que c'est un terreau fertile.
Un terrain fertile, donc fertile qui permet de faire pousser des plantes,
c'est une image.
Je regarde mes notes en même temps pour essayer d'être un peu structuré.
Le paradoxe, un peu, avec les mangas, c'est que si je prends Naruto...
C'est que l'histoire, c'est une histoire très japonaises.
Naruto, il est grandi dans un village de
ninja et tout
est construit sur des références japonaises.
Et c'est un peu bizarre parce qu'on se dit, mais un petit français,
quand ils commencent à lire Naruto, il doit trouver ça un peu bizarre et c'est des villages
de ninja.
Naruto, il adore manger des ramens, des nouilles, des soupes de nouilles
et les ninjas, ils font des techniques.
Enfin, toute la politique, tout ce qu'il y a dans le...
tout ce qui est action, etc.
C'est vraiment...
C'est très japonais, culturellement c'est très japonais.
Et ça c'est un peu un paradoxe, parce que
nous si je caricature,
les jeunes français on est enfin les petits,
quand on était petits on était plus habitués au truc du chevalier qui sauve la princesse,
au format un peu classique occidental, et moins à ce genre
de choses.
Pareil, il y a des...
Il y a des mangas comme Bleach par exemple, où ça parle d'esprit.
Au Japon, dans la religion Shintoiste,
les esprits occupent une place importante et du coup il y a beaucoup
de références à ça.
Peut-être pas dans Naruto mais dans d'autres œuvres, il y a beaucoup
de références à ça. Et on se dit bah, ça va pas plaire à un européen,
à un occidental, à un français, parce que c'est trop différent.
de sa propre culture.
Mais je pense que la réussite de ces
oeuvres, elle est due au fait
que ce sont des oeuvres qui abordent des thèmes assez universels.
Naruto c'est ce qu'on appelle un shonen.
Un shonen c'est en japonais ça veut dire jeune garçon, mais c'est un style
de manga assez précis.
Et si je fais un peu cliché, c'est un peu le jeune qui n'a pas vraiment
de talent ou qui est un peu nul
et qui d'un coup, enfin, qui a un très grand rêve
et qui d'un coup découvre qu'il a un pouvoir où il s'entraîne vraiment,
il s'entraîne énormément pour atteindre son rêve et à la fin il atteint ou pas.
Ça c'est exactement le cas de Naruto, donc Naruto au début c'est un raté,
il est nul, tout le monde le déteste quasiment
et lui son rêve c'est de devenir le chef du village en gros
pour protéger tout le monde et ça je pense
que ça touche à des thématiques universelles,
il y a le rêve, avoir un rêve et se tenir à son rêve,
vouloir atteindre ses rêves il y a le dépassement de soi c'est-à-dire s'entraîner,
essayer de devenir meilleur tous les jours il y a l'amitié, la vengeance,
l'amour, bref c'est des choses assez...
assez...
Assez universelles, et même si le cadre
est très japonais
Les enjeux qu'il y a derrière, c'est très universel.
Naruto, c'est l'optimiste naïf qui veut atteindre son but.
Lui, c'est vraiment tout le long, il dit, je veux devenir ça, je veux
devenir le chef, etc.
Alors que tout le monde lui dit...
Mais t'es un raté, t'es nul, etc.
Et ça il y a un peu, je pense que tout le monde peut s'identifier un peu à ça.
C'est-à-dire un peu ce truc de croire en soi, atteindre ses rêves, tout faire
pour atteindre ses rêves, etc.
Idem dans Naruto.
Il y a l'antagoniste, enfin non, c'est pas l'antagoniste mais c'est le rival
et l'ami de Naruto qui est le deuxième personnage le plus important
de l'œuvre je pense, c'est Sasuke.
C'est pas si on voit bien, mais c'est un peu l'inverse, c'est-à-dire que lui il est très renfermé,
il est animé par la vengeance.
Bon, il y a une histoire derrière sa vengeance,
il y a en fait son propre frère a tué toute sa famille,
donc peut-être que les politiciens avaient raison de dire que c'est un peu violent,
mais disons qu'on comprend pourquoi il est
autant en colère, mais on n'approve pas forcément.
C'est un personnage aussi très intéressant.
Mais du coup, la vengeance, ça touche
quand même à des choses universelles,
même si c'est très japonais.
Le côté universel des thématiques,
ça fait que n'importe qui qui lit un manga peut s'identifier.
Un autre point c'est une grande force des
mangas, c'est les antagonistes crédibles
et les héros qui doutent.
Ça c'est un point que je trouve intéressant parce que par exemple
quand j'étais jeune, il y avait tout
ce qui touchait au film de super héros,
notamment Marvel DC Comics.
Et au fur et à mesure, j'ai un peu perdu goût à ce genre de film.
Tout simplement parce qu'au bout d'un moment, je trouvais que ça devenait un peu cliché.
Et je pense qu'il y a un problème avec ce genre de film
quand l'antagoniste n'est pas très...
En fait,
j'ai l'impression que la qualité du film
ou de l'histoire peut se définir par la qualité de l'antagoniste.
L'antagoniste, c'est le méchant, c'est l'adversaire du super héros
ou du héros d'une oeuvre.
Et parfois, j'ai l'impression qu'on crée des antagonistes qui sont juste fous.
En fait, si le méchant il dit"je suis
méchant parce que je suis méchant","je suis méchant
parce que je suis fou","je suis complètement fou", mais que derrière,
on n'a aucune raison valable, en fait, on n'y croit pas vraiment.
C'est-à-dire qu'on voit ça, on fait "ouais, bon, d'accord".
Et si je prends un exemple, par exemple, il y a le bouffon vert.
Quand j'étais jeune, j'avais bien évidemment vu le film avec Toby McGuire,
et avec le bouffon vert, bon, il faisait peur, bien sûr, etc.
Mais avec un peu de recul, je ne me rappelle plus vraiment du film,
donc peut-être que je me trompe, mais avec un peu de recul, je me demande,
mais pourquoi, en fait, il est méchant?
Enfin, c'est quoi ses raisons?
Est-ce qu'il a des raisons valables pour être méchant comme ça?
Et en fait, si on ne peut pas répondre à cette question, je trouve
que c'est un mauvais antagoniste, c'est un mauvais méchant.
Un exemple plus récent dans l'univers Marvel, c'est Thanos.
Thanos, lui, en gros, il veut tuer la moitié de la population...
dans tout l'espace.
Et, pour le coup, quand j'ai vu le film, j'ai trouvé que...
C'était expliqué, il expliquait pourquoi il voulait faire ça, en gros il disait c'est
pour retrouver un équilibre Mais quand il explique dans le film on est presque à se dire,
franchement je comprends, je n'approuve pas les méthodes, je ne suis pas d'accord avec les méthodes,
mais je comprends
Et ça je trouve que, bon, Thanos c'est un bon antagoniste je pense,
mais je pense que dans Naruto par exemple, il y a des antagonistes
Fantastique.
Il y a, je pense...
J'allais dire parmi les meilleurs antagonistes, mais j'en sais rien,
mais...
Mais il y a des méchants, entre guillemets, vraiment très intéressants.
Il y a notamment un méchant qui s'appelle Pain
et Pain, lui, en gros,
il est là pour un peu tuer tout le monde.
Mais en fait, lui, ce qu'il explique, c'est que sa mission, c'est
de développer une arme suffisamment puissante pour
que les villages ninja ne s'attaquent plus entre eux.
Pain, quand il était jeune, quand il était enfant, ses parents ont été tués
dans une guerre et du coup, il a une certaine haine, mais lui, son objectif,
c'est d'avoir une paix totale.
Et il dit que pour ça, il va développer une arme tellement puissante
que plus personne n'osera s'attaquer.
Et ça
C'est la thématique de l'arme nucléaire, je veux dire.
Bon, c'est un peu cynique, mais si vous regardez la géopolitique actuelle,
c'est un peu ça.
Il y a des pays qui ont l'arme atomique et le
discours c'est que si on a l'arme atomique,
plus personne ne va oser nous attaquer, tout
simplement parce que on peut se détruire mutuellement.
en appuyant sur un bouton.
Et ça du coup quand on voit, quand on lit...
l'histoire de Pain, toute son enfance, etc.
et les raisons pour lesquelles il fait ça.
En fait, c'est très crédible.
En fait on comprend
pourquoi il pense ça
On comprend et pourquoi il croit que ça peut être une solution
On n'approuve pas forcément, on n'est pas forcément d'accord,
mais en tout cas c'est totalement crédible.
Et ça, ça quand il explique, il arrive même à...
Il arrive même à faire douter Naruto Naruto c'est vraiment
l'optimiste naïf Et à ce moment-là de l'histoire il arrive
presque à lui montrer par A+B Il lui
montre quasiment rationnellement
que les hommes de toute manière se tuent les uns les autres Il y a toujours eu des guerres
et que ce n'est pas en...
tenant des discours qu'on va régler toutes les guerres et que c'est
dans la nature humaine de vouloir dominer les autres et donc il dit
que sa solution d'avoir une arme tellement puissante
que plus personne n'oserait attaquer les autres.
Ça serait une solution.
Derrière, ça pose d'autres questions.
Il y a un autre manga comme Death Note, où le héros parle des mêmes thématiques,
Il découvre un pouvoir et qu'il veut être la justice.
Il peut tuer n'importe qui et du coup il prétend devenir la justice.
Et là c'est pareil, Pain, en soi si c'est lui qui a l'arme atomique entre guillemets.
En fait, il est un peu en train de prétendre qu'il peut devenir une justice absolue,
une sorte de Dieu.
Et donc voilà, et tout ça c'est des thématiques qui sont très intéressantes,
parce que...
Il suffit d'aller voir le film"Openheimer", il suffit de regarder l'actualité,
la guerre en Ukraine, ce genre de choses.
La Russie, la France qui possède l'arme atomique, pour comprendre
que c'est des thématiques qui sont très intéressantes.
Et ça, je pense que c'est vraiment
une des qualités de ce genre d'œuvre.
C'est qu'en fait...
On peut comprendre les méchants, les héros parfois, ils ont des faiblesses,
et en fait tout devient un peu gris, ce n'est pas vraiment blanc ou noir,
ce n'est pas...
Hyper, manichéen, ça veut dire que c'est Noir ou Blanc.
Spiderman
dans le bouffon vert, c'est un peu manichéen, Spiderman il a raison,
le bouffon vert il a tort, il a le bien et le mal et c'est comme ça,
et ça, si je prends d'autres
D'autres œuvres de manga par exemple.
Très récemment, il y a eu l'attaque des titans et
l'attaque des titans c'est un peu la même logique,
c'est un peu comme Game of Thrones, c'est-à-dire que c'est très politique.
Et que finalement, en fait,
il n'y a pas de personne qui a une vérité absolue,
tout le monde défend un peu ses intérêts.
Il y a des personnages avec une meilleure morale que d'autres.
Mais finalement, c'est plus une question d'intérêt et comment les personnages se battent
entre eux pour atteindre leurs propres intérêts.
Et ça, l'attaque des titans, c'est quelque chose que je recommande
si vous voulez commencer les animés, parce que c'est assez court pour un animé,
et c'est très...
C'est accessible, l'histoire est très intéressante.
Elle est très intrigante et donc c'est plus accessible.
Naruto, One Piece, des fois c'est trop long et du coup c'est peut-être moins accessible.
Il y a d'autres œuvres comme Berserk
où là c'est beaucoup plus violent,
mais c'est un héros qui s'enferme dans un cercle de haine et c'est pareil,
ça traite de ce sujet-là.
Et du coup, j'ai un peu l'impression que ces thématiques
-là, ces méchants compréhensibles,
ces grands antagonistes qui ont permis
de vraiment développer le manga
en France.
Là où, par exemple, les films de super héros, c'est toujours hyper populaire,
mais j'ai un peu l'impression qu'au bout d'un moment, ça s'essouffle.
Au bout d'un moment, le concept des films de super héros.
Moi, ça fait un moment que je ne suis pas allé au cinéma voir un film de super héros,
parce que la structure, c'est toujours un peu la même chose.
C'est toujours le héros qui a un pouvoir, un moment du film il doute,
et à la fin il arrive à battre le méchant.
Je caricature et je suis...
Peut-être un peu mauvaise langue, c'est-à-dire que je critique un peu facilement,
peut-être, mais j'ai un peu ce sentiment.
A l'inverse je parlais des héros qui sont imparfaits,
il y avait un film qui s'appelle"Logan", donc c'est"Wolverine", et j'avais beaucoup aimé ce film
parce que le personnage, le héros, donc j'ai oublié son...
j'ai oublié le nom de l'acteur.
Bon, bref, Logan, Wolverine...
Dans ce film, il est vraiment torturé, c'est un alcoolique, je crois qu'il se drogue,
et il n'arrive pas à prendre, enfin il est vraiment torturé, on voit
que ce pouvoir qu'il a, ça le
ronge, enfin, je crois qu'il est immortel
mais il aimerait mourir pour être...
Trouver le repos, enfin pour se reposer, enfin pour arrêter cette vie,
et voilà tout au long du film, du coup, c'est pas aussi manichéen que j'ai des
super pouvoirs, je suis super stylé et je vais aider tout le monde.
Donc ça, je trouve ça intéressant et je trouve que ça manque dans des oeuvres plus général
es et c'est quelque chose qu'on peut trouver dans les mangas.
Il y a des mangas très manichéens, il y a des mangas où c'est très"Je suis gentil, tu es le méchant"
et je sais pas pourquoi tu es méchant, mais je vais tout faire pour te battre.
Il y a aussi un truc qui est le format, c'est que...
Le marché du manga au Japon, c'est quelque chose de très particulier,
parce que en fait les œuvres, elles sont publiées dans
des publications hebdomadaires,
hebdomadaires ça veut dire chaque semaine, il y a publications quotidiennes,
chaque jour.
hebdomadaire chaque semaine
et après "mensuelle", "bimensuelle", etc.
Bon, bref.
Et en fait, il y a des publications hebdomadaires au Japon qui sont,
par exemple, un très connu, c'est le Weekly Shonen Jump, ouais, c'est ça.
Et ça en fait, les auteurs à partir du moment où ils commencent à être publiés,
ils doivent sortir des chapitres dans ces publications hebdomadaires.
Je crois que le rythme normal pour un mangaka, donc un auteur de manga,
c'est de sortir un chapitre par semaine, un chapitre toutes les deux semaines,
mais je crois que c'est par semaine.
Et en fait, le truc, c'est que...
Il y a tellement de personnes qui ont des histoires, qui créent des histoires,
que...
Quand déjà il faut être sélectionné pour être publié dans le Shonen Jump,
et quand vous êtes publié, il faut réussir à rester.
Et ça,
C'est les lecteurs qui choisissent, c'est les lecteurs qui votent,
et du coup chaque semaine les lecteurs vont lire un chapitre et ils vont décider
s'ils sont accrochés ou pas par l'histoire,
est-ce que les histoires les intéressent finalement,
et du coup ça c'est vraiment une compétition constante.
au sein des auteurs et ça implique plusieurs
choses, ça implique d'avoir une tension narrative,
c'est à dire que il y a un peu cette obligation de, à la fin d'un chapitre,
il faut donner envie aux lecteurs de lire le prochain, un peu comme dans les séries
si je prends l'exemple de Game of Thrones il y avait, je sais plus,
c'était l'épisode 9 ou ce genre de choses, enfin
Il y avait des épisodes où il se passait quelque chose de
très important
à la fin de l'épisode.
Et du coup, quand l'épisode est fini, on a juste envie de regarder le prochain.
Et du coup, la semaine suivante, on regarde l'épisode.
Et c'est un peu pareil avec les mangas, c'est-à-dire que,
comme ils sont publiés sous forme de chapitre,
Il crée une tension narrative à la fin du chapitre pour donner envie
de lire le suivant.
Ce qui fait que, quand on commence à lire NaRuto par exemple, si on est pris par l'histoire
si on...
L'histoire intéressante, on peut dévorer le manga, on peut vraiment lire tout d'un coup,
dévorer ses manger un peu comme un animal, un ogre,
et on peut vraiment lire le manga comme ça très rapidement.
Je crois qu'en anglais on dit un livre, c'est par exemple, c'est un page-turner,
on tourne les pages sans s'arrêter parce qu'on n'arrive pas, on est captivé par l'histoire.
Et ça, personnellement, je sais que quand j'étais
plus jeune, je me prenais plusieurs mangas Naruto,
je me posais et j'arrivais à lire, à lire, à lire sans m'arrêter parce
que j'étais captivé par l'histoire.
Il y a une autre chose, c'est que c'est un format très long.
Comme les séries mais là c'est encore plus long.
Je parlais de One Piece, One Piece il y a
pour l'anime, il y a plus de...
là on doit être à
1100 épisodes, donc
1100 épisodes de 25-30 minutes, c'est énorme et c'est super long
et quand j'étais jeune
One Piece, les mangas étaient publiés, je ne sais plus à quel numéro ils étaient.
Mais maintenant, il y a plus de 100 mangas.
Et donc ce qui fait que, bon, d'un côté, ça ne donne pas trop envie
de commencer.
Mais de l'autre, c'est que c'est tellement long que j'ai commencé à lire à 10 ans.
J'en ai 32 aujourd'hui, ça fait 22 ans que je suis une histoire.
Et ça, ça a créé une vraie attache émotionnelle.
Toutes les personnes qui ont commencé à lire
Naruto, entre 7, 10 ans,
peut-être pas trop tôt non plus, mais à 10 ans, en gros, ils ont fini Naruto à 25,
26 ans, quelque chose comme ça.
Et quand on sait que ça parle de thématiques comme la vengeance, se
dépasser, la colère, l'amour, l'amitié, etc.,
beh finalement, les jeunes, ils lisent ça au moment de l'adolescence,
etc.
Et c'est des choses qui les accompagnent dans un peu cette découverte,
et ça c'est...
Je pense que c'est hyper intéressant et du coup il y a une
vraie attache émotionnelle à ces oeuvres.
Si ma femme écoute une musique de Naruto, elle a très rapidement les larmes aux yeux,
par exemple.
Qu'est-ce que je voulais dire?
Et ça, ça rejoint le sujet d'une vidéo que j'ai faite, c'est que plus on passe du temps
avec quelque chose, plus ça...
a de la valeur, enfin, plus ça obtient de la valeur.
Bien évidemment, ça, c'est un style de manga très, c'est le style
de manga le plus populaire, les Shonens.
Il y a des, il y a des mangas plus adultes, on va dire, avec des formats plus courts.
Et par exemple, vous avez...
Urasawa Naoki, qui est un auteur et qui a fait, par exemple, Monster.
C'est plus comme un roman policier, mais sous forme de manga, qui est très intéressant.
Donc si vous n'êtes pas vraiment intéressés par ces longues histoires,
vous avez des choses plus courtes.
Il y a aussi, par exemple, en France, un mangaka
très populaire, c'est Jiro Taniguchi.
Et lui, il fait des mangas, c'est un livre.
Et par exemple, il y a le livre "Quartier lointain", qui est très populaire.
Mais voilà, il y a un peu de tout, il y a plein de formats différents.
Là je parle surtout des formats les plus populaires, on va dire.
Donc voilà
C'est, je pense, les raisons pour laquelle le manga est devenu hyper populaire
en France.
Il y a, donc pour résumer, il y a la
tradition BD qu'on a déjà en France.
Il y a aussi, en France, on a une culture du doublage, c'est-à-dire qu'on double
beaucoup les oeuvres, et du coup, il y a des doublages pour tous les animés par exemple.
Et donc, il y a des personnes qui ont grandi avec les voix françaises de Naruto,
One Piece, etc.
Et ça, ça fait aussi partie d'un peu de...
Ce qui a marqué une génération.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi, je ne sais pas si c'est
aussi populaire dans les autres pays européens.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi la France, enfin...
J'ai évoqué toutes les raisons, mais pourquoi la France en particulier,
je ne suis pas sûr.
Mais en tout cas, c'est quand même, je trouve des œuvres hyper intéressantes.
C'est destiné très japonais, mais les thématiques sont universelles et je pense que c'est
pour ça que c'est aussi intéressant.
Donc si vous avez envie de commencer un manga à un animé, n'hésitez pas franchement.
Il y a, comme on dit,
on utilise l'expression "il y a boire et à manger", c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plein
de choix disponibles, donc si vous essayez quelque chose mais que vous n'aimez pas,
essayez de...
regarder autre chose, regardez sur internet, il y a plein de catégories,
il y a des choses très violentes, des choses
très enfantines, des choses très shonen,
etc.
Je suis sûr que vous pouvez trouver quelque
chose qui vous intéresse et si vous avez besoin
de recommandation, N'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires ce
que vous aimez et peut-être que je vous recommanderez un manga.
Merci aux membres Youtube et aux membres Patreon qui me soutiennent,
ça me fait vraiment super plaisir et
pour cette vidéo donc il y aura 3 PDF disponibles
pour les membres, avec du vocabulaire, des exercices et des corrections,
et vous avez aussi accès
gratuitement au script sur Patreon.
Il faut juste avoir un compte. Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
C'est peut-être un vocabulaire plus spécifique,
donc peut-être que ce sera plus difficile à comprendre.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et à la prochaine.